ومع الخطط الغربيه بتقليد موسكو اقتصاديا
عسكريا على الارض تسير اوكرانيا نحو تحرير
المزيد من اراضيها بعد انسحاب روسيا من
خرسان تقاتل القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه
الان الروس في الجزر والمستنقعات الى
الجنوب الغربي من مدينه خيرسون في مسعا
لتحرير شبه جزيره كونغرسبرت نتابع واياكم
مع شبه الجزيره تلك التي تكتسب اهميه
استراتيجيه بسبب وقوعها عند مصاب نهر
النيبرو تحديدا عند التقائه بالبحر الاسود
يتركز القتال في كنبر على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهار الدي برو التي تتمتع بمناظر
الطبيعيه ساحره لكنها ستكون محوريه في
المرحله التاليه من حرب التحرير
الاوكرانيه سيطره روسيا على شبه الجزيره
في يونيو الماضي في واحده من اخر تقدماتها
الملحوظه هناك في الجنوب قبل ان تجبرها
ثياب على التراجع والتحول للدفاع تسمح على
شبه الجزيره لروسيا بابقاء قوه اعمق في
البحرين الاسود وحراسه الطرق المؤديه الى
موانئ في ميكو لايف وخرسون وحمايه قواتها
في شبه جزيره القرم اذا استولت اوكرانيا
على سبيت فانها ستضع خطوط امداد روسيه
التي تمتد شمالا من شبه جزيره القرم تحت
مرمى انظمه الاسلحه الاوكرانيه قال
فيتاليكن رئيس الاداره العسكريه في منطقه
ميكو لايف ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحرز
تقدما في كندرسبيت وسيطرت بالفعل على بلده
اوتشا كيف على بعد اقل من خمسه كيلومترات
من شبه الجزيره بينما قال مدونه عسكريون
روس ان القوات الروسيه تصدت الهجمات على
شبه جزيره كنغر سببت وفقا نقلته صحيفه
نيويورك
[موسيقى]
مشكله اخرى
جمهوريه وهي منطقه شمال غربروسيا على
الحدود مع فنلندا خطابا لبوتن يحضنه على
اصدار مرسوم يمنع الجيش من مواصله تعبئه
الجاريه بسبب اثاره السلبيه على المجتمع
كتبت ايميليا
عضو في الجمعيه في الجمعيه التشريعيه في
كاريليا ان التعبئه تمثل مصدر قلق متزايدا
للاسر الروسيه ومجموعات العمل والعديد من
الناس يعانون من مشاكل صحيه اضافت ان
التصاريح والخطب العامه الصادره عن
السلطات العسكريه ليست اجراءات معياريه
ليه ليس لها قوه قانونيه
هاتي الرساله بعدما اتهمت اوكرانيا روسيا
ببدا تعبئه سريه لتجميد المزيد من
المواطنين الروس في شبه جزيره القرم
المنطقه التي ضمتها روسيا من اوكرانيا في
عام 2014 هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ذكرت ان
اجراءات التعبئه السريه في صفوف القوات
الروسيه ما زالت جاريه في شبه جزيره القرم
في من نفى الكرملين قائلا انه لا توجد
مناقشات بشان تعبئه ثانيه او سريه
يوتيوب